Tulsi gabbard who as you guys know
former Democrat Tulsi gabbard she
endorsed a whole bunch of Republicans
and and campaigned with a whole bunch of
Republicans before this election it did
not turn out that well but I can tell
you
that I know Tulsi believes she did the
right thing and you don't always win
everything in politics uh well she's
still beating the drum on the issues
that she cares about one of the big ones
is Tech censorship so although the
candidates that she was backing did not
do that well her star to me is still on
the rise because she's still positioned
as sort of a center-right same person
ex-lib kind of thing so she was guest
hosting for Tucker Carlson last night
and she had a nice monologue when it
came to how Democrats work with big Tech
to actually subvert democracy
unfortunately while in Bali today
instead of delivering a necessary
message of unity to all Americans
President Biden chose to attack half the
country once again implying that the
only acceptable Democratic outcome is a
win for the Democratic Party
let me start with a few words about the
recent elections held in the United
States
what we saw was the strength and
resilience of the American democracy and
we saw it in action
and the American people proved once
again that democracy is Who We Are
and there's a strong rejection of
election deniers at every level from
those seeking the lead to our states as
long as the Democratic Party in the
permanent Washington Elite are working
hand in hand with Google and Facebook
and as long as Google is allowed to
continue to use its Monopoly power to
skew public opinion in a certain
direction literally manipulating the
information that we as voters are
allowed to see then there is no
democracy
a recent study by researchers at North
Carolina State University found that
Google's email service Gmail quote
retained the majority of left-wing
candidate emails while sending quote the
majority of right-wing candidate emails
to the spam folder
additionally Google has greatly reduced
the visibility of various conservative
websites in its search results
yeah she's kind of right on that and it
reminded me of the clip that we showed
you yesterday of Senator Marco Rubio
talking about how the chips are so
stacked against those of us that believe
in Freedom right I don't even want to
say conservatives those of us that
roughly believe in Freedom and that
America is a decent place you've got big
Tech against you you've got all the
corporate power against you you've got
the cultural hegemony against you the
fact that these elections are so close
and that Republicans don't do all this
early drop-off stuff in early voting and
all that right generally Republicans
tend to show up on Election Day and like
that paper trail oh I filled this thing
out I dropped it in myself they're going
to counter it right then and there we're
going to have some transparency when it
comes to these elections Marco Rubio
what he was saying was the fact that all
of that stuff is against us and these
elections are close show you that
actually we do have the right ideas
that's really the same thing that Tulsi
is talking about there that in essence
with so much misinformation that is
promoted by democrats such as Sunny
Hosten right 28 year old voting that's
what the Republicans want even though
she completely made it up the fact that
we are able to keep these things as
close as we can shows you we've got
something good here and we just have to
figure out how to fight back better